- Les automobilistes auront
bientôt un raccourci pour passer
d'un quartier à l'autre
de ce secteur de Longueuil.
Les travaux de prolongement
du boulevard Béliveau avancent
rondement depuis la fin
de l'été...
(coassement)
... Au grand dam de ceux
qui veulent protéger
cette petite grenouille
menacée d'extinction.
ALAIN BRANCHAUD, biologiste
et dir. général, SNAP Québec
- Tous les habitats de rainettes
faux-grillon, l'essentiel
des habitats de rainettes faux-
grillon vont être détruits par
un développement domiciliaire.
- Longueuil attend le
prolongement de ce boulevard
depuis des dizaines d'années.
HANS BROUILLETTE, affaires
publiques, Ville de Longueuil
- Il y a des véhicules qui sont
tout simplement en transit,
traversent dans des quartiers
résidentiels où circulent
des vélos, des enfants. Ça n'a
tout simplement pas de bon sens.
- Rien pour convaincre
des groupes environnementaux
qui demandent à Ottawa
de faire cesser les travaux.
GENEVIÈVE PAUL, dg, Centre
québécois du droit de l'environ.
- Nous exhortons aujourd'hui
le gouvernement fédéral à agir
rapidement et par décret en
vertu de la Loi sur les espèces
en péril.
- Une source a confié
à Radio-Canada que le
gouvernement Trudeau s'apprête
à promulguer un décret d'urgence
qui mettrait un terme à tout
développement dans le secteur,
comme il l'a fait à La Prairie,
en 2016.
D'ailleurs, le ministère
fédéral de l'Environnement
confirme avoir entrepris
des discussions avec Québec.
La Ville de Longueuil tient
à rappeler qu'elle a reçu l'aval
des deux paliers de gouvernement
pour aller de l'avant
avec le projet.
- Si à l'interne même
du ministère, des gens changent
d'idée en cours de route,
désolé, mais nous, ce n'est pas
la responsabilité de la Ville
de devoir changer de cap
au gré de l'opinion
des uns et des autres.
- La Ville de Longueuil
a construit ce corridor
de biodiversité pour permettre
aux rainettes faux-grillon
de passer d'un côté à l'autre
du boulevard Béliveau, mais
des groupes environnementaux
mettent en doute la capacité
des grenouilles de trouver
ce passage vers le boisé
du Tremblay.
- Ce n'est pas une espèce
qui a une grande capacité de
déplacement, alors le corridor
qui est proposé est tellement
ténu, tellement étroit
qu'il ne va pas passer
au travers d'habitats propices
pour la rainette.
- D'après le ministère
de la Faune, au Québec,
20 % des rainettes faux-grillon
vivent dans ce secteur.
Ici Elyse Allard,
Radio-Canada, Longueuil.